no show at work for the previous two
days
arrived at work he pulled into the
parking garage and as a result of once
he pulled into the park
parking garage and used his proxy card
and entered the garage
that triggered security due to the fact
that he had not been at work
that employee drove up to the
fifth floor of the parking garage and
parked his vehicle
as a result of him entering the property
security
went to check on his welfare the
security officer
walked up to the vehicle and as soon as
he approached the vehicle was met by
gunfire
at the car door the security officer was
pronounced deceased
at the scene the suspect then walked
away from the vehicle
and then shot himself with one
self-inflicted gunshot where he was then
pronounced deceased at the scene
i want to stress that this is in a
secure parking
structure there were no other people
around and it was a very remote part of
the
parking garage the employees involved
all notifications have been made to all
of their families so at this point
there's the notifications to the people
involved have been made
with that i will take a couple questions
but again it's very early on
in the investigation
no we don't believe there's any link
between the security officer
and the shooter we again the security
officer was sent to check
due to the fact that the employee
arrived at the property after not being
at work for two days
and due to the security procedures here
that's what prompted them to
once he arrived on property to check on
him
the security officer who is deceased is
a hispanic male
in his early 30s anything else would
have to go through the win as far as
releasing that information the suspect
is a hispanic male and he is in his
early 40s
again we have no idea as far as what led
him to
take the actions that he took today
again he was
for two days was previously a no call no
show at work
and that's what prompted security to
check on him when he arrived on property
it happened right at the door of his car
he was
sitting in his car when the officer
checked on his welfare
and was met by gunfire
there were no other employees that were
in the vicinity there was an employee
along with the security officer who had
went up there
but she was not in the immediate
vicinity of when the gunfire took place
again he's an employee at the hotel i'm
not going to get into the specifics of
his occupation
firing in a here especially after what
we you know witnessed on one october
uh how did metro respond to this how
quickly were you here how many resources
went into responding and figuring out
what's going on
well i want to make sure there's no
there's this is an isolated incident
of work workplace violence you there's
no
link whatsoever uh to one october you're
dealing with a hotel that has a very
robust security procedures
as far as you know when you're dealing
with private sector you're not going to
get
a better trained and more technical
technology and
utilizing technology than the hotels on
the las vegas strip
and this property has an exceptional
security
response and they handle this extremely
well with their own internal pro
their internal response as far as metro
we are anything that happens
we're going to bring as many resources
that we need to bring to make sure that
the citizens and the tourists in this
valley are
are safe and that's you're going to see
a heavy police presence
anytime you have an incident of violence
anywhere on the las vegas strip
i'm not going to get into specific
locations of where the victim was shot
again i don't know we're still trying to
figure out what the what led
up to the shooting and why he was you
know he arrived on property
obviously he was armed with a handgun
when he arrived
he stayed in his car what is commendable
is the fact that the wind did an
exceptional job when you think about
how they instantly recognize that he was
on their property
they instantly sent someone to check on
why he had returned to the property
and that's what happened so as far as
the hotel their response was absolutely
exceptional to him coming on property
being armed
the victim is a hispanic male in his
early 30s
the suspect is a hispanic male in his
early 40s
he was shot multiple times
thank you guys